Every once in a while, you get a craving that you
simply can't control: You absolutely, positively
need to watch a number of Batman movies. If you
feel like having a Batman movie marathon right now
and don't have the time or inclination to track
down a bunch of bat-movies from different sources,
then Netflix is your friend. The streaming
service carries a nice variety of Batman films,
and they're different enough that you won't ever
get bored. In fact, you'll be able to enjoy a
whole bunch of different takes on both the Caped
Crusader himself as well as his rogues gallery,
from Academy Award-winning efforts to
delightfully goofy animated creations.
"OMG it's Batman. Batman."
What's up to you is not only which
of these titles you decide to watch,
but the order in which you choose to view them.
Thankfully, we've got some ideas about how to
pull off a Gotham City-themed movie marathon
with style, but first, here's every Batman
movie you can binge-watch on Netflix right now.
There are currently four Batman films on Netflix,
which is scientifically the optimal number for a
proper movie marathon. In case that isn't
exciting enough, two of the Batman movies
present on the streaming service right now are
"Batman Begins" and "The Dark Knight," the first
two installments in director Christopher
Nolan's acclaimed "Dark Knight" trilogy.
Together, the pair of live-action Batman movies
give you the chance to spend a good few hours with
Christian Bale's grounded, growly version of the
Bat. In addition to Bale's version of Bruce Wayne,
"Batman Begins" and "The Dark Knight" also feature
several truly memorable takes on some of the Caped
Crusader's most iconic villains, including Liam
Neeson's Ra's al Ghul, Cillian Murphy's Scarecrow,
Aaron Eckhart's Harvey Dent AKA Two-Face,
and, of course, Heath Ledger's Joker.
"You look nervous. Is it the scars?
You want to know how I got them?"
The supporting casts of both
films are also undeniably stellar,
with reliable heavy hitters like Gary Oldman,
Michael Caine, Tom Wilkinson, and Morgan
Freeman all showing up at various points as
important and notable DC Comics characters.
Unfortunately, the third installment in Nolan's
Batman trilogy, 2012's "The Dark Knight Rises," is
not on Netflix right now. If you're set on sitting
down and marathoning the entire Dark Knight
trilogy, that means you'll have to look elsewhere
to watch its final chapter. The good news is that,
even without "The Dark Knight Rises," both
"Batman Begins" and "The Dark Knight" offer
more than enough of the thrills necessary to make
one Netflix streaming session feel worthwhile.
There are two other Batman movies available
to stream on Netflix right now: "Batman: The
Killing Joke" and the 22-minute "LEGO DC Comics:
Batman Be-Leaguered." The former title pits Kevin
Conroy's Batman against Mark Hamill's Joker in
an adaptation of Alan Moore and Brian Bolland's
classic graphic novel. "Batman Be-Leaguered,"
meanwhile, sees a Troy Baker-voiced LEGO
Batman and the nascent Justice League embark on a
global battle against a truly surprising villain.
The two animated titles could not
be more different from each other,
or from the Christopher Nolan-directed live-action
films that Netflix also has to offer. Fortunately,
that means there's room for you to toss some real
variety into your Batman-centric streaming plans.
Depending on how you want to approach your
bat-marathon, you could start with something
serious like "Batman Begins," and then follow that
film up with its actual sequel, "The Dark Knight."
From there, you could let Heath Ledger's
fan-favorite Joker act as your gateway to
true chaos as you slide from the comparatively
realistic Nolan-verse to the even darker world
and more sinister plot of "The Killing Joke."
Finally, as you're winding down from the non-stop
chaos of "The Killing Joke" and "The Dark
Knight," there's no better way to step out
of the darkness of those films and back into the
light than by turning on "Batman Be-Leaguered."
"Ugh, I lose more Batsubs this way."
Alternatively, you could start soft and go from
"Batman: Be-Leaguered" to "Killing Joke" and end
with "Batman Begins" and "The Dark Knight," or
even sandwich the animated films in between the
two Nolan movies. After all, it's your movie
marathon. There are no rules — there's only...
"The Bat Man."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.